good afternoon mr depp
good afternoon
can you please tell the jury why you're
here today
um
yes
um
about six years ago um
uh misheard
made
some
quite heinous and um
disturbing
brought these disturbing criminal um
acts
um
against
uh me there were
arguments
and
things of that nature
but never
did i myself
reach the point of um
striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
i'd probably been in the industry 30
plus years 35 years
um
never have had any
problems anything like that
and i had met many people
over the years many many of the people
and had had
the opportunity to talk to those people
and to
um even
give advice to these people
and
i'm
i'm not
my goal is the truth
my goal is the truth
because
it it killed me that
people that i had spoken with that i had
met with over the years who i who maybe
were in a
not such a great position and they
needed advice
and i gave them
the best advice i could
um
all i could think of was that those
people
would
would
think that i
was a fraud and that i had lied to them
and
so i had to wait
for my opportunity to um
address the charges
which were
criminal charges
um
and and then they just weren't um true
so i i felt
the responsibility of
clearing the record
as um
the only
the only way that i could get that i
could
get to the point where i could speak
um has
really
taken
this full six years and it's been six
years of
trying times
it's very
strange when
one day you're
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds you're
quasimodo
and um i
i
i didn't uh
deserve that nor did my
children nor did the people who have
believed in me for
all these years i i didn't want anybody
any of those people to
believe that i had
done them wrong or lied to them or that
i was a fraud
i i
i pride myself on honesty i pride
my cell phone truth truth is the only
thing i'm
interested in
other
lies will get you nowhere but um
lies build upon lies and build upon lies
it's too much to cover i i
i'm obsessed with the truth and um so
today is my
actually my the first
opportunity that i've been able to
speak about this
case
in full for for the first time mr depp
how do you feel about the intimate
details of your life being aired in this
process
as a father
raising kids
you know when they were very very little
um it was important to me
very important to me
to
[Music]
to try to
shield my children as much as possible
from
um
looking at their father
uh or their or their mom for that matter
uh
as uh
novelties
i i didn't want my children to
experience
hordes of paparazzis
so i was always a very private
person
so for me to
come up here and stand before you or sit
before you
all
and
spill
the truth um
is quite exposing
and um
it's unfortunate
that it's not only exposing
for myself it's exposing for my
family it's exposing for misheard it's
exposing for
it's um
it never had to go
in this direction
and so i
i can't say that i'm embarrassed because
i know that i'm doing the right thing
how did your experiences observing your
parents as a child
affect your approach to your
relationship with miss heard
well
in the beginning of my relationship with
ms herod
there
was
from what i
recall and what i remember she was
she was um
[Music]
it was as if she were it was she was too
good to be true
um
she was
attentive she was
loving um
she was smart she was
kind she was funny she
was understanding she
um
and we we had many things in common
certain
blues music and
well music
literature things of that nature so
for that year
or year and a half it was uh
it was amazing um
there were a couple of things that
i don't know stuck in my head that i
noticed that i thought
might be a little bit of a
a dilemma
at some point
for example
if i if i
i was i worked quite a lot
and when i would
come home from work
um
i would i would
come in the house or the hotel
and
she would sit me down on the couch
and give me a glass of wine
and
uh take my boots off
set him to the side and
um
i'd never experienced anything like that
in in in my life i i just never thought
i was
i just never experienced that before
and it became a regular thing
um
that she did
this kind of routine
and i remember one night i came home
from work and
i think she was on the phone or
something and
her busy she was doing something and
um
so i sat down on the couch and i took my
boots off and um
suddenly
miss her approached
with this
look on her face that she and she just
said
what did you just do
what did you do
what do you mean
you took your boots off
i said
i said yeah yes i did you you you were
busy you know no no no that's my job
that's what i do
you don't do that i do that
okay
all right then
and then she said let me get you a glass
of wine she brought me the glass of wine
but i did take pause of course
at
the fact that she was
visibly
shaken or upset
that i had
i had broken her
rules of routine
i thought that strange and then
once that once you notice something like
that
then you start to notice other little
tidbits and things that come out
and then
and then
within a year or year and a half
she
had become this
another person what did you like about
miss heard when you first
started your romantic relationship
she seemed to be
she seemed to be the
um
she seemed to be the
perfect
uh
partner
in a sense
in my head for me because she
as i said she
she was she seemed to be very
knowledgeable about
old obscure blues music that i
listened to and really liked
she
was literate she was
sweet
funny
nice all those things you know um
and and and she was
from the beginning of our relationship
at that time
for a good year year and a half um
she was
she was wonderful
and and then
things just
started to
change or
things started to reveal themselves
that's i think is a better way to put it
you mentioned earlier in your testimony
that miss heard would would take off
your boots when you would get home from
work
what other types of
behaviors did you observe and misheard
early in the relationship
um
[Music]
little things that you would kind of it
would just
you'd question in in the back of your
mind you know if
if uh
if
she wanted to go to bed
i'd say oh well
i i can't sleep you know right now
and rather than go and just lay in a bed
and stare at the ceiling
i would say
uh you know i'll just watch i'll be out
here watching tv or hanging out and and
that was just not acceptable
it's not acceptable
it would uh it would steer up
some some rather
unusual
reactions from her i i didn't understand
why i
as a 50 something year old
man
was not allowed to go to sleep when i
wanted to
uh as opposed to when she wanted to it
started out with little things like that
and again they they just
they eventually they just
i suppose like anything
if they're allowed to continue then they
then they are allowed to
grow they're allowed to blossom
into whatever they're going to become
when did you first meet miss hurd's
parents
i first met miss hurt's parents when
uh they they had come out to los angeles
i believe and uh yeah
and and uh
i feel i feel like that i met them
i think they came to
my place to
um to my studio
and um
there were two completely
opposite ends of the end of the spectrum
people page
um
was um
she was an angel
she was an angel
and uh
and uh i loved her very much i i i loved
her instantly
and we had a very good relationship um
her father
david was the opposite end of that he
was this
outrageous kind of
almost like a cartoon cowboy you know
and he was um
the initial thought i mean my initial
kind of definition
for david would have been
rascally like a rascal you know
um
but i
i
i loved i mean i grew to love them both
very much
as well as her
her sister whitney
and um
yes it it felt like i had been welcomed
into some sort of
family
i had been accepted into this
this family and
those relationships stayed
solid
until just a bit after
we'd
separated how would you describe your
relationship with whitney
great i mean fantastic
she was
i called her sis
i loved her you know i felt
i had always felt something
i'd always felt like whitney had missed
out on something
same objection
we can move on okay
where was whitney living when you first
when you and miss heard first started
your relationship
she was living with her
then boyfriend sean kraszyski
was this in the same
where was miss heard living when you
first started your relationship
uh miss former miss miss herd had
informed me that she just moved
to a new place on
orange avenue
what city is that in los angeles sorry
yeah and
was a whitney also living in los angeles
whitney was living in los angeles yes
whether with sean
kraszewski and uh
yeah
so how often would you see whitney um
when you and miss heard were in a
relationship oh a lot um whitney would
uh
whitney would come over all the time
with her boyfriend for
dinners and
such uh
ms hurt always liked having um
people over you know for dinner
parties and
socially shows you know social kind of
events that are at her at her
place
have you ever done any drugs with
whitney
[Music]
yes
how often would you do that
with whitney
yes with whitney
maybe two two three times maybe twice
three times
now you said you did drugs a couple
times with with whitney um what what
drugs were you doing with whitney
whitney and i had
done
a line or two of cocaine together
when did you start getting introduced to
ms heard's friends after you started
your relationship with her
almost immediately well in fact
immediately yeah
immediately
i was introduced to
[Music]
the whole gang you know
rocky
io
brittany eustis
whitney certainly um
um
who else
that this all comes to mind at the
moment
you